Film Courage: Do you think the first sentence
or scene in a screenplay is important as it
might be in a novel?
Naomi Beaty, Writer, Screenwriting Teacher
and Consultant: That’s a good question.
I haven’t thought about it but I would say
no.
Only because I think in a novel…well I don’t
know?
When you’re reading a novel you’re going
to give it more than one sentence right?
I mean if you’ve picked up a novel to read
you’re probably pretty interested in it
already.
In a screenplay I have heard…so it depends
on the situation.
If I am reading this entire script and I already
know I’m reading it front to back then that
first sentence if it’s clunky I’m going
to give it a little leeway.
I’m going to give it another chance right?
So I’m going to keep reading regardless.
I have heard some people say that they can
tell if they are going to keep reading a script
from the first sentence.
If they read the first sentence and they are
not hooked or it feels like the person doesn’t
really know what they are doing then they
are going to put it down.
I would say that is an extreme opinion.
But you also have to understand that if we’re
talking about a situation where you are submitting
your script to be read by somebody in the
industry you are asking for their time.
How much time they are willing to give you
is up to them.
So the best thing you can do is make sure
every sentence of your screenplay is worth
reading and makes them want to read the next
one right?
You have to set yourself up for success because
there is no guarantee that they are going
to read your whole script.
Film Courage: That’s fair.
And this is by the way you said you’re hearing
this from producers or agents or whomever.
This is not necessarily your opinion?
Naomi: Right, I mean I very rarely just pick
up a script just to read one sentence and
see if I like it or not.
But it depends on the situation so if someone
is reading a lot of scripts, if they are vetting
scripts for a producer say and they’re just
looking for something really great, they might
only give it a page or two pages.
Back in the day when I was reading a lot of
scripts for a producer and so I wasn’t reading
the scripts to try to give notes and try and
make it better.
It was just vetting projects to see if there
was anything interesting or worth reading
the whole script.
It wasn’t uncommon to read the first act
or even to where the inciting incident should
be and see if anything is happening, see if
there is anything to like sort of catch my
interest and make me want to keep reading
this script.
I think if you’re submitting your scripts
to a producer or a manager or an agent, you
should assume that you need to hook their
attention at least in the first few pages
if not on the first page itself.
Film Courage: And this goes back to the story
you said about being from Oregon and “Hey,
how’s it going?”
When you’re working at a production company
and when you called to the Los Angeles area
[for business purposes in the entertainment
industry] it was more protocol for them to
be like “Yeah?
What do you need?”
Well intentioned I’m sure they are but that’s
the tempo of the industry and it wasn’t
to find out how your day was going?
Naomi: Yes, exactly.
The pace in Los Angeles, that’s what surprised
me when comparing Oregon to California.
From Portland to LA the pace was definitely
a lot faster and that took some getting used
to.
But yes I think that speaks to…that’s
exactly right.
People working in the industry are short on
time and there’s a lot of material to get
through and you have to make your material
grab them and make them want to keep reading
and that is a challenge.
Question for the viewers: How much thought
do you put into the first sentence of a screenplay?